e à europa que fazer uns vídeos clicando
os negócios relacionamento negócio e tal
mas eu também não sei de tudo né e tem
um canal que conhecia que eu acho que
pode explicar melhor pra vocês é o canal
acidentes e menina
esse é o tipo de vídeo que você vai
assistir vai querer repassar para todas
as pessoas que você conhece até ver se
chega na sua mãe sua irmã na sua amiga e
na sua namorada
[Música]
ok 10 euros um canal do youtube de
mulher que não façam maquiagem sobre
moda essas coisas lá essas coisas que
você quer descobrir mas tem lá aquela
velha onde tentará passar me edital
então se inscreve la clicando aqui
esquece comentar no último vídeo que foi
indicação minha eu não entendo muito
emprestar 4 milhões com a senhora bush
na volta e aí galera cantando alto com
vocês mas está tudo bem ea escola
militar ea nova namorada tatiana 0 falar
até 107 botafogo
achei que meu mandato eu estou de boa
notícia pra vocês falam luiz seu cartel
desarmado meu filho não mais se claro
pois pronto arrumei a mãe só para você
tira bagunça que é cenografia ele no
chão e conseguiu chegar nem à cerâmica
galera se de um bairro para outro
caminho e chegar serão que afecta a lei
eu queria passar pra você vai ter que se
fazem para cá só existem duas maneiras
que você embarca uma maneira ímpar
sozinho ea outra maneira ela passa
ninguém eu estou falando é certo que uma
pessoa dentro da casa quando você está
limpando é suficiente para infernizar
enquanto não seria aqui também
enquanto alonso da renault também lá em
cima também e você não tem um curso onde
no ato do dia empatado nem quando sua
mãe quando você não vai continuar
limpando pelo amor de deus não é
dedicada calçado não e cava um dia sem
querer alguém tiver embarcado e você
entrar reze peça a deus peça para
qualquer ser esse universo orione maior
ipo fé para que não seja a sua mãe pano
por quem reza a lenda que se você chegar
na rua os pés urgente além de casa sem
avisar
você morre porque coisa que ama coisa
gere cal coisa de deus coisa que há mais
amor no coração é mãe agora pisa no chão
limpo a tribunal pela desgraça na
memória mas cheguei a entrar ano
eu sei que você está pensando no 122 não
que eu não goste é uma casa não goste da
china anunciou alguma coisa essa outra
lenda
se você começar a arrumar suas roupas
foi vez que você achar dinheiro a paz
você ganha 10 milhões de reais na mega
sena é bom agora você achar 50 centavo
no bolso local se você não esperava que
achar o doido é coisa de deus o deus do
céu que é isso aqui
[Música]
obrigado obrigado a vocês a minha casa
fazer umas 15 séculos é normal né e
lógica foi na esperança de achar logo
aqui na minha casa eu achei é claro que
sim e não treinou e não foi nesse dia
foi nessa hora que eu fiquei feliz que
arrumar meu pato partiu do modelo você
deixar a limpeza sua casa mais legal é
chapa chamada você chamar de mac por
exemplo eu estou em pânico admita as
olimpíadas de inverno
[Música]
o papa copa
outra coisa você tem que fazer não se
estressa muito anos sua mãe reclama da
sua vez que acessar a mãe nunca sagrado
quem faz o desvio chegou para mim e
falou assim oh meu deus de balcão aqui
tá cara de quem pouco falei brincando né
mãe igual eu apanhei
agora vou cantar a música pra você 2 do
doido torre do doido doido se tornou uma
lacuna nesse vídeo e enfiar ritla do
ligada no tempo da série a-1 líquida
aqui pra nós quer saber o que você mais
odeia o que é que você mais gosta
voltarem para casa comenta aqui embaixo
é a primeira vez que você tá vendo meu
canal você clicar em inscrever-se em
baixa com toda tiver de novo já sabe